Paul what have we learned then we've
learned the bank has taken a very big
decision uh historically big decision as
far as interest rates are concerned it's
doing it because they believe the
situation is very grave let's have a
look at what they have actually done
today they have increased interest rates
by 0.75 percentage points that is the
biggest single increase over here by me
in the very late 80s there was a a
one-day leap that was slightly bigger on
black Wednesday it's the largest since
the bank was grass into Pennsylvania
that has raised interest rates to three
percent over at the far end you can also
see that stepping up there that is eight
consecutive leaps in interest in
interest rates eight consecutive
meetings so the bank has been tightening
interest rates all year why is it doing
it well it's doing it it's the bank
Governor made clear there in the press
conference because in his words
inflation is too high and you can see
why 10.1 percent is where inflation sits
at the moment it's been up there it was
above in July dip Down Below in August
but it's pretty stubbornly high the
highest since back over here this is
again the 1980s now what's driving that
and what's as we all know is the energy
Crisis began before the war in Ukraine
exacerbated by it's driven up inflation
you see all of that is in the last year
and the bank's job is to drive that down
to two percent and so we heard the
governor say they have no choice
effectively but to act he said that is
they do so very interesting to hear a
central Banker concerned with macro
economic issues very technical
technocratic but in all his answers
certainly prefacing those remarks about
he understands what that will do to
ordinary people facing a cost of living
crisis as another issue that they talked
about which is important about looking
into the future is what does what
they've said today mean about the path
for interest rates Beyond Today these
are the market expectations for interest
rate so this is what the money markets
think will happen to interest at various
points this year if we go back to Feb
before The Invasion the lower of the
light blue lines here see it comes into
the middle of next year end of next year
Market's thinking below two percent well
that didn't last long we get to the
summer and August the energy crisis is
in full flow but still the projection
was that rates would be below three
percent now the mini budget in September
which was actually after the bank of
England last had a chance to comment on
this and make a decision that sent rates
soaring the projection people thinking
this is going to be above six percent
now that has fallen back somewhat but
the bank saying today that they believe
despite the fact they've made this
really big hike historically in interest
which they actually think the Market's
overdoing that number and they think
that rates might Peak lower so they will
have to they will rise more we can
expect further interest rate increases
but they won't Peak as high now we'll
see what the Market's reaction is to
that news one other thing we haven't got
we haven't had time yet to draw the line
in here but look we're looking in to
July 23 October 2023 bank is very clear
in August they predicted a five-quarter
recession so that's a year and a bit the
bank today confirming it believes we are
already in recession and they expect the
recession albeit perhaps not as deep as
previous recessions to last all the way
that line would be drawn below not with
GDP falling Beyond you into the first
half of 2024 so an almost two-year
recession predicted by the bank of
England so while there's some crumbs of
good news about the path for interest
rates and controlling inflation these
are very very tough bits of information
and tough news from the bank of England